[Music]
hey Mia have you seen my phone no oh I
did see one on the women's bathroom oh
okay yes I'd love a glass of the Pinot
Grigio great I'm just going to see
already really sure you know I changed
wallets I think I left my other wallet
hey can anybody bring me a towel
everybody home I'm really excited to
have you and hey Michelle this is our
new intern Stacy to meet you thank you
so much I gotta go wait what was your
name
seriously hey Mia do have a phone dryer
I can borrow thank you so much I'll get
it right back just need it for ten
minutes
okay that's tonight that's tonight oh
god no
are you kidding me damn it
Oh No today length the stove on oh no it
doesn't Facebook that as me as birthday
today
shoot no I told her I'd take you to
Disneyland for her birthday I really
wanted to get her something cuz she got
me beyoncé tickets for my birthday I
didn't get her a Christmas present just
now hey guy happy birthday thank you got
you from both of us thank you uh here's
I love it
[Music]